street art is ephemeral meter-high
artworks that grace entire facades
aren't made for eternity the buildings
can get torn down or repainted so legal
or not street art is transitory by
nature now the urban nation Museum in
Berlin is out to bring street art
indoors it's one of the world's first
permanent museums for contemporary urban
art
but can art born on the street really
work in a museum street art belongs on
the street and should stay there here at
the urban nation museum we asked 130
artists who normally decorate building
walls to come up with an artwork
measuring one meter by one meter 50 for
the museum but at the same time we will
continue to work with these artists on
large outdoor projects of health and
vitality the aesthetics and styles of
various street artists are now captured
on canvas this helps visitors identify
the artists work out on the street
it's been positive about I'm surprised
to see street art in a museum
expectations were high but now it's
amazing
like the the collection is Wow close
little speck I have great respect for
the people who organized this getting
the people together and the artists
creative director Yasha young spent two
years working with nine other curators
around the globe to select the artists
for the project
the exhibition showcases urban
contemporary art giving a relatively
young genre a place in art history but
the new museum wants to be more than
just an exhibition space the museum's
aim is to create a repository for urban
art the first exhibition provides
insights into the developments
techniques styles and diversity of urban
art
the urban nation museum also showcases
artists who work in different genres
like Berlin based artist Mimi is the
former street artist now works digitally
in a studio but it's still clear where
her roots are mission it's an honor for
me to be represented here to be here as
an illustrator and digital artist or
digital painter with a relatively new
medium that isn't so widely accepted and
only recently found a degree of
recognition I fought for 10 years for
this so the feeling is indescribable
with its framed canvases and orderly
structure the current exhibition seems
like ones found in conventional museums
however the building's architectural
design will provide plenty of space for
experimental shows in the future topics
Eva the building is flexible enough for
us to paint entire walls that are 20
meters high we can paint the facade or
remove it and add new elements to it the
inaugural exhibition runs until next
summer
then the exhibits will make way for new
works of street art but no fear rather
than being destroyed the outgoing pieces
will be stored for posterity